bonsoir jérôme rodrigues merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france une
première étape soit importante donc dans
ce dossier quelle est la réaction à ces
décisions alors la réaction elle est un
petit peu confuse parce que j'ai quelque
part du mal à concrétiser ce que peut
représenter une mise en examen donc donc
c'est j'ai du mal un petit peu analysé
les choses après avec du recul en
entendant par là même en entendant
parler mon avocat et diverses personnes
c'est quelque chose qui est quand même
assez énorme apparemment équipe qui peut
porter ses fruits maintenant on va
éviter tout triomphalisme et on essaiera
d'être heureux le jour où la sentence
sera rendue et que la justice ne sera
rendue
en tout cas il ya une forme même si
évidemment il n'y a pas eu de jugement
bien évidemment il ya une forme de mise
en responsabilité potentielle de ces
policiers c'est quelque chose en tout
cas qui compte pour la victime que vous
n'êtes pas très clairement parce que ça
fait deux ans qu'on est quand même dans
l' attente d'une décision quelconque au
vu des preuves et de l'ensemble des
vidéos qui ont été tournés ce jour là
sur le sur l'acte du l'acte du 26
janvier 2010 neuf jours où j'étais
bornier c'est regrettable que ça prenne
autant de temps il ya d'autres affaires
en justice à laquelle je suis convié où
ça prend beaucoup moins de temps donc
bon voilà c'est un bon début forcément
j'espère qu'on ira au delà de ça et
qu'on pourra aller au jugement pour
pouvoir déterminer l'ensemble des
responsabilités de la chaîne de
responsabilités face à ce qui m'est
arrivé je suis resté patient pendant
deux ans en essayant de parler un
minimum justement de de la faire pour
que celle ci puisse aller au bout sans
avoir de
de soucis maintenant que cette annonce
et est apparue et qu'on va laisser faire
un petit peu le phénomène médiatique je
vais retourner dans le calme et laisser
faire à la fois les juges les enquêteurs
et l'avocat leur travail pour pouvoir
justement pouvoir récupérer justice
presque deux ans après cette décision
enfin depuis les actes comment justement
vous expliquez vous cette longueur
écoutez la première surprise c'est que
j'étais parti du principe que temps que
notre président macron s'arrête au
pouvoir il serait difficile que
j'obtienne justice donc bon déjà la
justice m'a fait mentir quelque part et
j'en suis agréablement surpris
maintenant
maintenant faut vraiment que ça aille au
bout et que et que
et que le travail puisse bien se faire
vous savez le problème en soi c'est pas
la justice on parle beaucoup de la
justice moi j'ai un parti pris qui est
le suivant pour que la justice puisse
bien faire son travail il faut en même
temps qu'elle puisse avoir les bonnes
pièces les bonnes preuves toutes les
pièces justificatives qui permettront à
la justice ou de justement pouvoir être
rendu aujourd'hui les enquêtes
appartenant à l'igpn donc des policiers
qui enquêtent sur des policiers
est ce que toute la lumière est faite
justement de parler rapport de l'igpn
pour que pour que la justice puisse se
faire c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui je
milite aussi pour que il puisse y avoir
des enquêtes indépendantes pour en tout
cas sur les exactions de policiers
vis-à-vis des citoyens pour que la
justice puisse avoir les bonnes pièces
et être rendu pour l'ensemble des
victimes et de leurs familles selon vous
jérôme rodriguez cette affaire votre
affaire est ce qu'elle est devenue
politique en quelque sorte
alors quoi qu'il arrive je suis devenu
un opposant politique du mois à la
politique de macron donc au vu de ce qui
se passe dans de nombreux pays
il est clair qu'on cherche à me faire
taire il n'y a pas eu que l'impact
l'impact de la balle ou de la grenade
qui m'a éborgné le 26 il ya tout ce
qu'ils ont sonné suivi en terme de
pression sur ma vie sur sur les
désagréments qu'ils ont pu suivre sur
les mises en accusation que j'ai pu
avoir de la part du gouvernement ou de
la part de certains ministres ou députés
vous avez se faire traiter de débile
mental en direct à la télé il faut quand
même de la part de responsables au
gouvernement faut quand même encaissé ça
pendant pendant deux ans 100 ans sans
même pouvoir avoir un droit de réponse
par me parmi ces gens là bien entendu
donc
ils m'ont fait je vais vous dire ces
gens là le gouvernement l'état la
pression qu'ils ont mis à la fois sur
sur ma personne et sur ma famille m'ont
fait beaucoup plus de mal que les deux
policiers qui m'ont crevé l'oeil quand
vous parlez de pression j'ai un pneu ne
paieront jamais de leurs responsabilités
quand vous parlez de pression vous
pensez à quoi
vous savez des contrôles d'impôt sur ma
famille des contrôles d'urssaf je me
prends j'en suis pratiquement à 2000
2500 euros damende des amendes que je ne
reçois pas à mon domicile à laquelle on
ne les signifie pas dans la rue parce
que je vous rappelle que je suis persona
non grata pour messieurs l'allemand le
samedi à paris et au final elles
finissent par comment dire atterrir sur
la somme de 400 euros il vient
directement se servir sur mes comptes
des rappels d'impôts avec des sommes à
payer enfin voilà beaucoup de choses
vous je ne cache pas les insultes que je
peux prendre de la part du gouvernement
ou les faits que muse que j'ai pu
recevoir de la part de madame schiappa
ou autres insultes de la part de
nombreux policiers sur les réseaux
sociaux ou autres ce qu'on appelle troll
aujourd'hui c'est très très compliqué à
vivre c'est ce que je suis depuis deux
ans au même titre que beaucoup de
personnes au sein du mouvement et qui
ont été épargnés c'est ce qui est le
plus dégueulasse
au final de s'en prendre à quelqu'un
alors qu'on soit d'accord ou pas avec
rodriguez qu'on soit d'accord ou pas
avec les gilet jaune se servir de
l'infirmité d'une personne pour pouvoir
le le le
lui nuire je vous cache pas les menaces
de mort que je peux recevoir tous les
jours ça commence un petit peu affaires
à faire lourd quoi psychologiquement
parlant alors les deux policiers en tout
cas sont sous contrôle judiciaire
aujourd'hui mise en examen on le disait
s'est responsabilisé erté pardon du
policier se sont pas les responsabilités
du donneur d'ordre des donneurs d'ordre
c'est pas plutôt à eux que vous en
voulez aujourd'hui j'en veux quand même
quelque part aux policiers
dans l'absolu parce que je n'y a aucune
réponse à son acte avant de pouvoir
pardonner parce que tout être humain a
peut-être la capacité de pouvoir
pardonner tout en essayant d'avoir une
explication à son geste
aujourd'hui ce qui est regrettable c'est
que dans l'histoire vous avez quatre
victimes parce que vous avez aussi mon
ami michael qui s'est pris qui s'est
pris une balle au niveau du tibia qui a
le tibia sacrément sacrément blessés
vous avez aussi les deux policiers qui
sont victimes de la situation quelque
part victime responsable parce que c'est
eux qu'ils avaient les armes en main et
qui ont qui ont su mal les utiliser à
mon encontre c'est une certitude mais
que vont payer
d'une certaine façon ils sont déjà en
train de le payer c'est à dire qu'ils
sont mises en examen je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas facile à
vivre leurs familles doivent le subir
aujourd'hui je sais ce que c'est je sais
ce que c'est
enfin vous voyez ce genre de contexte de
justice de s'en prendre plein la tronche
et de prendre quelque chose comme ça
dans sa vie de payer de sa
responsabilité
j'imagine que c'est pas facile pour eux
et c'est ça qui est dommageable
aujourd'hui parce que les vrais
responsables
aujourd'hui sont les donneurs d'ordre
monsieur delpech le le le préfet en
place à l'époque des faits monsieur
nunez qui a menti le soir des faits
monsieur castaner qui est aussi un
menteur et qui qui est aussi donneur
d'ordre et j'en passe pour monsieur
macron aussi désolant d'ordre sauf que
aujourd'hui ces personnes là sont des
super citoyen en france qui ne méritent
pas justice de par leurs fonctions ce
qui est complètement regrettable parce
qu'ils auraient dû être exemplaires
alors ils n'ont pas de données en tout
cas je n'ai pas la preuve exacte et
précise qu'il aurait donné l'ordre car
est-ce qu'on me tire dessus
mais en tout cas ils n'ont pas donné le
contente de pouvoir enlever ses armes au
sein des manifestations au vu des
désagréments qui peuvent infliger
physiquement à l'ensemble de
manifestants qui a rappelé que je suis
le 20e manifestants à être éborgné qu'il
y en a eu 20 avant moi que le premier
n'aurait jamais dû exister je rappelle
qu'il ya au moins cinq à six femmes qui
ont été épargnées il ya eu cette main
arrachée
on parle de là on parle de la mise en
examen des policiers concernant la
sphère rodrigues mais vous avez aussi
des examens des mises en examen qui ont
été mis qui ont été faites pour la faire
gwendal le roi qui est aussi un copain
qui a perdu un oeil à rennes
il est important de préciser que c'est
le parquet qui avait fait appel d'une
décision de de non poursuite de
judiciaire vis-à-vis du policier qui a
eu beau renier mon copain voilà
maintenant il est temps que la justice
se met en place pour l'ensemble des
manifestants parce que fait important
les 30 éborgné et 5 mutinés au sein des
manifestations n'ont jamais étaient
poursuivis pour violence sans la
manifestation donc mérité quelque part
encore moins de se prendre une balle en
pleine tête
aujourd'hui il ya une loi qui fait débat
vous le savez le beauvau notamment de la
sécurité 1
est ce qu'il est nécessaire selon vous
pour rétabli
les bons rapports entre la population et
la police mais complètement encore
faudrait-il que les citoyens soient
conviés à ce genre de réunion
il est facile aujourd'hui de faire une
réunion entre soi ses tripes typiquement
macro nhien j'en veux pour preuve le
grand débat à l'époque
voilà des petites réunions d'entre eux
soit c'est pas la première je pense
depuis le quinquennat enfin du moins du
moins depuis le début du quinquennat de
du président macron voilà donc on va les
laisser discuter de savoir comment mieux
éborgné et surtout de pouvoir
communiquer derrière pour pouvoir ne pas
être impliqué dans tout les mutilations
et toutes les horreurs qu'ils sont
capables de pratiquer en manifestation
je trouve regrettable aujourd'hui que ce
type de réunion les citoyens ne soient
pas convié de là je reviens à leurs
revendications une des revendications
gilet jaune qui est celle d'avoir
d'avoir une démocratie directe et
participative
on en veut pour preuve que même pas un
mutilé même pas un simple citoyen puisse
se trouver à ce type de réunion pour ne
serait ce que donnait de la voix et
justement essayer d'améliorer le
quotidien à la fois des policiers et des
citoyens parce que je le rappelle
aujourd'hui moi j'ai un problème avec
les policiers qui sont censés maintenir
l'ordre au sein des manifestations et
non pas la police du quotidien ce qu'on
appelle les gardiens de la paix qui sont
malgré tout utile à la population parce
que quand nous arrivons en demi on est
bien content de les trouver malgré tout
la france a été épinglée un jérôme
gleizes part
un port un de ses économistes comme une
démocratie défaillante en 2020 alors
c'est vrai que si on va dans le détail
de cette étude on parle des restrictions
dues à la crise sanitaire mais enfin
c'est un constat que vous vous partagez
la france est devenue une démocratie
défaillantes selon vous écoutez ça fait
deux ans qu'on le crie haut et fort vos
équipes ont l'habitude de nous suivrons
manifestations cela fait partie de notre
principale revendication vous savez la
deuxième série de lois liberticides que
veut mettre en place macron qui fait
pour faire référence à l'article 24 qui
fait partie des articles qui font le
plus de 2 de polémiques faut savoir que
le gilet jaune n'en sont pas à leurs
premières lois liberticides aujourd'hui
on vit dans un paradoxe nous il est
jaune c'est qu'on a été interdit à un an
et demi deux ans de porter un masque au
sein des manifestations pour ne pas
subir les gaz et aujourd'hui on nous
oblige à mettre un masque
donc vous savez les lois liberticides
quelque part on est responsable nous
gilet jaune mais on en est victime aussi
depuis depuis maintenant deux ans de par
les arrestations arbitraires de pas de
come on est traité au sein des
manifestations vous rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui on a simplement essayé de
me faire taire on me crevant un oeil
donc ça si c'est pas une entrave à la
démocratie mais est le plus le plus
abject dont dans cette histoire c'est
que vous avez un président macron qui se
permet de donner des leçons de
démocratie à d'autres pays qui mérite
sûrement d'avoir des leçons mais
lui-même fait pire encore oui il ya
certains opposants politiques qui se
retrouve en prison aujourd'hui dans le
monde - ma prison je la porte
aujourd'hui chaque matin que dieu fasse
donc les rapports aujourd'hui qu'il soit
de d'amnesty comme le dernier qui a été
sortie face aux arrestations arbitraires
de the economist
face au manque de démocratie aujourd'hui
en france face à doha d' au rapport de
l'onu si vous vous souvenez ou même
certains ministres et députés de la lru
m
on en sait ne sachant même pas de qui il
parlait alors vous avez vu le
gouvernement aujourd'hui vous avez le
président fin de non-recevoir je veux
dire ça glisse comme sur l'eau et
continuera de mener des exactions au
sein des manifestations pour justement
faire taire l'ensemble avait constaté
des contestataires
aujourd'hui il ya une grande partie de
la france qui souffre peut-être encore
davantage qu'avant avec une perte de
revenus conséquente dans beaucoup de
secteurs avec la crise du coc vide
est-ce que 2022 va être en vous le grand
retour des gilet jaune une fois la crise
sanitaire passé après stéphanie je tiens
à rappeler les gilet jaune ce n'est pas
une idéologie le gilet jaune c'est une
métaphore c'est de pouvoir mettre un
gilet jaune
enfin du moins un gilet fluorescent
parce que aujourd'hui la majeure partie
des français qui construisent qui
travaillent qui sut qui donnent leur
sang qui donnent leur vie à la france
pau pour pouvoir travailler de de
pouvoir refaire redorer la france sont
invisibles
elle est là la métaphore vous avez un
mouvement populaire à partisans mais qui
est un melting-pot de l'ensemble des
français aujourd'hui vous avez toutes
les générations confondues toutes les
religions confondues tous les métiers
confondus tous les corps de métiers
confondus
au sein de cette manifestation et
aujourd'hui il est important de le
préciser et qu'on finisse par l'entendre
que ce n'est pas ce ne sont pas des gens
à part voyez on est des simples citoyens
qui travaillent qui subissons
aujourd'hui les restrictions sanitaires
du coc vide au même titre que n'importe
qui pour moi un gilet jaune aujourd'hui
peut être un simple restaurateurs
fatigués de la situation fatigués de ne
pas pouvoir travailler de ne pas pouvoir
gagner sa vie au même titre que les
petits commerçants qui aujourd'hui
souffrent de la situation au même titre
que les stations de ski que que fin que
tous les métiers et tous les travaux
aujourd'hui en france qui sont impactés
par ces par ces mesures
son gilet jaune à partir du moment où on
n'est pas content et qu'on va à
l'encontre du les décisions du
gouvernement
le mans il faut aujourd'hui arrêter de
faire l'amalgamé avec toutes les
saloperies qu'on a pu entendre sur
différents médias attention je ne parle
pas de rtl que de devenir s'intéresser à
ces gens là assez gilet jaune qui
travaillent dans l'ombre pour pouvoir
proposer pour pouvoir revendiquer
apporter des solutions pour permettre à
mieux vivre aux français des groupes de
pensée sur la démocratie directe
participative qu'elle prenne le chemin
du rich ou pas que de se concentrer sur
des phénomènes de violence qui sont des
effets de loupe médiatique sur des
manifestations je vous garantis que le
mouvement est bien plus haut qu'il n'est
décrit dans les médias et que il gagne à
être connu et qu'on puisse s'intéresser
aux gens vous savez aujourd'hui on vit
dans une société où on est complètement
dépersonnaliser le simple fait d'arriver
en manifestation de demander le prénom à
quelqu'un de savoir ce qu'il fait dans
la vie est de savoir pourquoi il est là
la personne quand elle vous parle ça lui
fait du bien
il faut aujourd'hui qu'on puisse se
reconnaître qu'on ait quelque chose de
beaucoup plus humain vous pour espérer
une vie meilleure vous savez je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la france mérite mieux
que d'enchaîner les éborgné elle a une
histoire ce pays a une histoire allait
quand même la mère patrie des droits de
l'homme
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on devrait
s'inquiéter parce que le constat et les
suivants il est plus difficile de gagner
des libertés que d'en perdre merci
beaucoup jérôme heures au ray est
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france merci à vous